why did we draw this thing what topic
are we in and what relevance does it
have
apart from funny patterns to anything
we're learning in this course
what's the topic binomial theorem what
what is a binomial
binomial bi means two no you'll mean
something with terms right
so it's this thing right so that would
be
so more than one would be polynomial
right poly mini
so we're just looking at these guys
things with two terms and then when you
raise it to some kind of power
one of the first examples we thought was
one plus x to the power of three
okay so we can expand these things and
when we do that
we find that these
numbers whoops sorry these numbers
from pascal's triangle mysteriously
appear
so that's why this this has appeared
right but clearly there's some structure
going on here
and we want to be able to talk about it
number one
without having to draw out pascal's
triangle every time and number two
in general terms right now that's harder
to wrap your head around
this is harder to conceptualize
than this right because i can write down
the first number
but after i've written down my first
number i don't know what to write
because i don't know what n is so i
don't know what row i'm in so i'm stuck
okay so i'm going to introduce some
language some notation
which will allow me to dig at this
without even knowing what n is okay
so let me introduce this to you let me
define it for you okay write this down
with me
ncr is ncr is a number okay
in particular it's the coefficient
of x to the power of r in
this precise binomial okay
i should say in the expansion of that
binomial but that's kind of implied
isn't it
right so let me give you a nice easy
example
stemming from this guy okay wrap this up
we have all of the coefficients one two
three
four and now i can write them without
knowing what they're actually
equal to using this notation okay now
pay attention
ncr right and i do write it with that
funny
superscript normal subscript format okay
ncr the n refers to the power that i
have okay
so in this case it's three
so let's have a look at this one this
first coefficient right
it's going to be three c now
what will be this number down in the
bottom corner this r number
now it's kind of hiding there isn't it
it's the um it's the
power of x that i've got but in this
case the power of x
is zero isn't it you see why
mathematicians often start at zero
it's not just arbitrary it actually
makes sense in this context okay so that
that first number there namely one right
that's 3c 0 that's the definition of 3c0
this next number along right ncr so the
n
is still that power it still stays the
same it's going to be 3c
but the power's moved up one hasn't it
okay so this is three c
one and now you can just kind of unfold
the pattern from there you've got
three c two there and
hiding in there that one in front of the
x cubed that's going to be three
c three now i'm just going to pause for
a second just to caution you because i
know in this class
there are going to be a significant
enough number of you
that you recognize that this this means
more than just what i'm defining it to
be it has a much broader meaning
than what i'm i'm starting with okay but
i want us to start here and we'll get
there in time
and it will be confusing if we introduce
it all at once before you understand how
the pieces fit together
okay so if this is a particular example
remember one of the reasons why i was
pulling out
introducing this whole language is so i
can start to generalize
and not just think about what is to the
third power of the fourth power of the
fifth power
but to any power right so let's write
this out
what is one plus x
to the power of n in this scheme how
would i write it
okay well because it's starting with a
one right
i could say it's always going to be one
no matter what
n i have the first term will always be
one
but i can write it in a more helpful
descriptive way
right see how the number at the top the
end that's staying the same all
the whole way through and it relates to
the power
so the first term should be n c
zero right so that top term is going to
stay put
if you want to think about it this way
it's up the top just the same way the
power is up the top so you can sort of
match them together
there's the first term yeah the next
term
the n stays the same but i'm moving up
1 by the power right which of course
means there must be an x term that comes
with it
right and now my pattern continues i'm
going to have x squared
i guess i'd have x cubed
and so on okay now i don't know what n
is right so this
series of terms is going to go for some
undetermined amount of time
but it does end it's not infinite right
what would be the very last term
on the end okay so yeah yeah
okay first my x will be just like here
this power is going to match what you
started with right and then secondly i
think doris who said it
the coefficient is going to be n c
m okay so that all matches up
right so far so good does that make
sense
okay now just before i um
go into this and introduce c notation on
your calculator which you should get out
now
um ncr notation it's all right you can
see it on the screen
ncr notation is on your calculator you
might not have noticed it
if you go down to your big buttons there
right and if you look on top of the
multiplication and division signs
you see these operations hanging out
there which you've never really paid
attention to
right you'll notice there's an npr which
is nothing to do with national public
radio in the us
and there's an ncr which clearly by the
way they set out
have something to do with each other but
we'll dig into that in the future
okay ncr is the one i'm interested in so
for instance let's have a look at this
guy
three c zero i punched that in in my
calculator by saying
three you're going to have to go shift
let's turn no that'd help
three shift zero so you get that funny
looking c
right which is its way of indicating
this right so i've literally
written it three c zero okay and as we
expect when you hit equals
you get one okay so for those of you who
are kind of like
oh man i have to keep flicking back to
where i've drawn pascal's triangle i
have to keep looking at this thing right
remembering that these coefficients
match up exactly to these numbers
right for instance let's just do a quick
experiment
how would you work out a term like
okay so 462
that's the biggest number in in my
pascal's triangle that i've drawn out
okay what ncr does it correspond to
now do it slowly with me what's the n
stand for
stands for power right which in pascal's
triangle means it stands for
row right that's that's the power that
i'm interested in is the row that i'm
looking at
okay so this is the 11th row does that
make sense
so i've got n equals 11 here now which
term am i actually interested in right
there's two ways you can think about
this firstly i can just count them up
can't i so i've got term zero zero
one two three four five
turn five there right so this should be
it should be
eleven c five right
let's check it
sure enough okay that was the first way
you could have just counted it out
there's another way of thinking about it
before drawing any of this
if i tell you on row of pascal's
triangle
you ought to be fairly easily able to
tell me how many
terms there will be in that row because
they keep getting bigger don't they
for instance the third row has four
terms
the seventh row has eight terms so the
11th row is going to be
12 terms right now if there are 12 terms
watch out i start from zero
zero and then one two three
four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven now the question i posed at
the beginning
was i wanted the biggest term there the
biggest term in any row of pascal's
triangle will always be the
middle one right in the middle because
there's symmetry to it yeah
so some of them have one middle term why
does this one only have one middle term
because it's got an odd number of terms
right so there's one right uh
it depends on if you're thinking about
yeah n or the actual number of terms
right so this is the nth row with n plus
one terms
yep so in this case you can see it's
going to be terms five
and six right the way that i would think
about that i guess is
the way i get middle is by bisecting by
dividing by two
right so that would be 11 divided by
two right which is five and a half which
tells me either of these would be fine
does that make sense
okay